et bien bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans
cette 4e édition des tournesol live
c'est un plaisir de pouvoir animer ce
soir ce live avec vous euh et bien
bonsoir Titoan bonsoir comment vas-tu je
vais très bien je suis en période
d'examen mais euh je prends un peu de de
de plaisir à faire des des interviews
autour de sujet intéressant pour faire
euh changer aussi un peu les idées un
honneur et alors nous avons avec nous
aujourd'hui une invitée spéciale Fiona
alors ce n'est pas exactement Fiona tu
vas nous peut-être nous en dire plus
après mais Valentine de lâre donc tu as
une page Wikipédia qui donne des
informations sur toi c'est
vrai on est et moi pour le coup j'ai pas
de page wikipédia et donc je suis je
suis
absolument fasciné par ça Valentine dere
tu es une vidéaste etour journaliste
scientifique française nous dit ta page
wikipédia tu as un intérêt pour la
géologie et tu es également nommé
Chevalier de l'Ordre des Arts et des
Lettres voilà bah écoute Valentine c'est
un grand plaisir de t'avoir avec nous si
on t'a invité c'est aussi parce que tu
as une chaîne Youtube qui s'appelle
science de comptoir qui est une chaîne
qui est extrêmement bien notée sur
tournesol donc on va être là aussi pour
parler un petit peu de tes
vidéos voilà bah est-ce que tu peux te
présenter et nous dire un petit peu qui
tu es oui bien sûr d'abord merci
beaucoup de de m'accueillir ici bonjour
à tous donc comme tu l'as dit je suis
Valentine et aussi un petit peu Fiona
qui est dans le derrière enfin dans le
derrière dans le fond on la voit pas
elle est par terre ça commence déjà très
très bien donc j'ai une chaîne Youtube
depuis 2015 qui s'appelle science de
comptoir sur laquelle je parle
essentiellement de caillou mais pas que
j'aime bien aussi parler de de biologie
d'environnement ce genre de truc et
j'essaie de le faire sur un temps un
petit peu drôle de temps en temps et à
côté de ça aussi je travaille avec Milan
presque un éditeur jeunesse et enfin un
éditeur un groupe de presse jeunesse
donc mil en presse euh et je travaille
sur la chaîne Youtube qui s'appelle info
Myo qui parle de d'éducation média
esprit critique ce genre de truc et je
réalise pour eux une série de vidéos qui
parle justement de théorie du complot et
qui démontre un peu des idées reçues
autour des sciences voilà la dernière
parle du nombre d'or tu as montré très
tôt un intérêt pour la géologie moi
c'est une science que je connais très
mal est-ce que tu pourrais nous
expliquer un petit peu ce que c'est et
pourquoi justement tu t'es porté vers
cette discipline ouais bien sûr bah la
géologie en fait elle est partout c'est
l'étude des je sais pas quel est le vrai
terme l'étude de la terre l'étude des
roches en fait c'est bah tout ce qui est
autour de nous enfin derrière moi c'est
les seuls murs qui sont pas en pierre
autour de moi parce que pi apparente
sinon et vraiment la la géologie c'est
absolument partout à la fois bah B c'est
c'est aussi les minerais qu'on utilise
pour vivre c'est bah les les murs autour
de nous comme tu l'ai dit c'est plein
plein de choses et puis c'est aussi
l'histoire de l'histoire de la Terre de
comment on est arrivé là l'histoire des
volcans l'histoire de il y a tellement
de choses qu'on peut étudier même au
fond des océans tout ce qui est
océanographie c'est aussi de la géologie
donc en fait la géologie est absolument
partout mais on s'en rend pas compte et
pourquoi j'aime la géologie en fait il y
a deux raisons la première c'est quand
j'étais petite mon frère avait sa les
espèces de kits de minéraux avec plein
de minéraux différents et tout et ça me
fait je passé des heures à les regarder
surtout le souffre qui est bien bien
jaune là magnifique et je l' snifé aussi
des fois parce que ça fait partie du jeu
et donc ça c'est quand j'étais petite et
mais je m'intéressais à aux sciences
naturelles au sens large cé vraiment pas
que la géologie et après ce qui m'a fait
aller vers la géologie après le bac
c'était pour fuir C c'était pour fuir
certaines disciplines de la biologie que
j'aimais pas tout ce qui est bio
biochimie enfin même génétique et tout
je vraiment c'était barbant coup je je
me suis dit bon ben je vais aller en
géologie et et j'ai bien fait puce que
c'est c'est après le bac que j'ai
découvert à quel point la géologie était
partout et à quel point c'était hyper
intéressant parce que c'est là où tu es
en contact avec directement les
chercheurs qui bossent dessus et qui
peuvent te partager leur passion quoi et
ça c'est hyper cool et après je me suis
fait rattraper parce que j'ai fait un
master en en biologie évolutive donc là
j'en ai bouffé de la génétique ça
m'apprendra j'imagine bien et et du coup
en alors je sais pas comment tu t'es
organisé mais tu as aussi étudié le
journalisme
ouais ouis absolument euh après mon
Master alors pour faire tout mon tout
mon cursus après le bac j'ai fait une
licence en ou là pardon pour ce beaucoup
trop vif j'ai fait une licence en
géologie après j'ai fait un master en
biologie évolutive don je parlait et
après ce master là j'ai fait une année
de cisure pour faire ma bourgeoise et
après je suis revenue et j'ai fait un
master en 2 ans de journalisme
scientifique un master qui se fait à la
suite d'une formation scientifique donc
c'est vraiment conçu comme un deuxème
master ouais euh voilà donc c'est c'est
très cool et c'est une formation qui est
à Paris dans laquelle j'enseigne
maintenant donc c'est pour ça je fais un
peu la pub donc Paris 7 euh et ce qui a
bien avec cette formation c'est qu'elle
est pas mal accé sur l'audiovisuel aussi
donc c'est vraiment quand j'étais dans
ce master là que j'ai ouvert ma chaîne
et que je j'ai vraiment mis le pied à
l'étrier parce que les profs étaient là
pour me conseiller il prêtaient du
matériel aussi il me disaient mais vas-y
pour tes projets perso utilise notre
matériel et et donc mes premières vidéos
que j'ai faites c'était grâce à leur
matériel et à leurs conseils et euh et
donc je leur dois beaucoup
trop bien et alors à côté de ça tu as
aussi bossé pour la pour le magazine
Science et Avenir c'est bien ça ouais
absolument ouais ok est-ce que tu peux
nous parler un petit peu justement de
cette période là tout à fait alors j'ai
commencé par faire un stage chez eux
quand j'étais justement dans ce master
de journalisme scientifique d'ailleurs
je les salue si jamais ils nous regarde
parce que je je les aime beaucoup j'ai
fait ce stage vraiment on s'est hyper
bien entendu j'ai adoré bosser là-bas cé
vraiment très très cool et à la fin de
mon master ils m'ont rappelé en disant e
on a eu un un job de journaliste vidéo
si tu veux donc je leur ai dit bah manui
bango c'est trop bien et et du coup DEP
fil en aiguille j'ai bossé 2 ans pour
eux et et c'était hyper cool parce que
c'était un peu le job de reporteur donc
soit je je faisais des sujets dans mon
coin avec caméra au point et tout et je
faisais donc je faisais l'écriture
tournage montage soit j'accompagnais un
journaliste on partait en binôme sur le
terrain et donc eux préparent le ils
faisaient le boulot de journaliste donc
ils préparaient l'interview ils
interviewaient les gens tout ça et et
moi je faisais juste l'aspect technique
enfin
juste le fait de de cadrer et après je
montais la vidéo et et on écrivait
ensemble souvent il y a des articles et
des vidéos ensemble donc c'était cool de
pouvoir travailler en commun comme ça et
j'ai travaillé avec à peu près tous les
gens de la rédaction comme ça donc
c'était très chouette et un autre
avantage d'être à la vidéo c'est comme
j'étais la seule à ce poste je pouvais
vraiment être généraliste donc bosser
sur absolument tous les sujets
ccientifique et ça c'était vraiment très
très chouette trop bien ça t'a permis
d'approcher des chercheurs ou pas ce tr
travail absolument et pas que ouais euh
ouais ouais ouais j'ai vu Cédric vellani
j'ai vu des ministres attention
Jean-Michel Blanquer euh Frédéric Vidal
en bref et plein de plein de chercheurs
hyper intéressants des chercheurs pas
qu'en géologie
aussi le découvreur de mince de Lucy
j'ai oublié son nom feu le découvreur de
Lucy qui qui était que tu as pu
rencontrer ouais ouais ouais ou était
encore vivant OK oublié son nom attendez
voir
euh euh oui oui oui lu si enfin bref
vous voyez quoi y copins voilà y copins
ok P à son âme euh
ouais donc en fait c'était hyper cool de
pouvoir justement approcher des
chercheurs et être au contact d'eux quoi
ce que je disais avec la passion en fait
quand j'étais à la fac et je rencontrais
les chercheurs qui m'enseignaient des
trucs avec passion et ben dans
l'interview ça se retrouve et vraiment
quand tu sors d' d'une interview avec un
chercheur passionné tu es tu es
requinqué quoi vraiment c'est c'est
c'est enfin c'est c'est un peu grisant
ouais j'imagine ok trop bien euh et
ouais pour parler un petit peu justement
des débuts de ta chaîne Youtube est-ce
que tu peux nous parler un petit peu euh
bah voilà des débuts comment ça s'est
passé quelle a été ton approche
justement pour construire des vidéos
est-ce que tu as tout tout de suite
commencé avec ce format dont on va
parler un peu plus en détail mais qui
qui est bien particulier que moi
j'apprécie vraiment beaucoup
euh voilà ouais donc en fait j'avais
déjà un blog donc je vulgarisais à
l'écrit je faisais un peu du dessin et
la vidéo ça j'avais jamais testé et ça
me faisait très très envie mais cétait
un truc énorme et insurmontable à mon à
mon hble vie du coup je m'étais dit
toute seule je peux pas m'en sortir quoi
et justement le master est tombé à pic
parce qu'il y avait justement les
compétences techniques humaines et et
matériel pour pour que je me lance je me
suis dit allons-y donc j'étais bien
encadré dès le début en fait et même les
premières vidéos sur la chaîne on les a
faites à trois avec mes compères et gan
à la base on était trois sur la chaîne
enfin c'est moi qui les poussé vraiment
très fort et ils ont fini par me dire
non bah c'est bon fais ton truc quoi
nous embête pas et mais voilà pendant
pendant un petit moment j'ai essayé de
de les inclure dans truc parce que
c'était chouette d'être
trois je me suis lancée dans la vidéo au
début on a commencé par des petites
interviews des trucs comme ça un peu
sans prétention et enfin sans prétention
mais avec des des invité de haol on a eu
David lo on a eu pierre carner enfin
c'était c'était des interviews de
vulgaris
au début du temps où il y en avait pas
encore trop sur Internet et et c'était
hyper cool de de les avoir qu' puissent
nous donner leur tips and tricks et
compagnie là et c'est hyper hyper
chouette de pouvoir discuter avec eux
euh et donc ma première vraie vidéo
YouTube c'était une vidéo sur le
l'intelligence des pigeons qui éta en
face caméra là aussi il y a plein de
péripéties avec cette première vidéo
j'ai dû la retourner complètement parce
que je me suis fait jeter j'ai tourner
dans un endroit où il fallait pas
tourner et bref il y a plein plein de
péripéties c'était au au au cimetière du
père la chaise à Paris ok apparemment tu
as pas le droit de tourner au au
cimetière parce que en fait chaque
concession appartient ouais je me suis
fait violemment jeter non mais on avait
fait ça en mode on était venu avec un
trépied et tout par le cimetière par le
les les mecs de la sécurité du cimetière
vraiment ils sont venus en petite
voiturette ils m'ont dit vous vous venez
avec la caméra là ils m'ont traîné dans
le dans le l'espèce de Guiton où ils
étaient là et ils m'ont fait supprimer
les rushes devant eux vraiment j'ai
l'impression d'être une criminel quoi
alors juste je faisais une vidéo sur les
pigeons enfin bref donc j'ai retourné
cette vidéo et tout c'était vraiment
long et euh mais c'était vraiment cool
et j'ai bien aimé et tout de suite j'ai
eu des bons retours des gens donc je me
suis dit ah je vais continuer c'est
chouette j'en ai fait quelques autres et
puis après euh je me suis dit alors
comment ça s'est fait j'ai eu un format
autour de l'actualité scientifique que
j'aimais beaucoup que j'aimerais faire
revenir aussi mais ça j'en ai pas encore
parleré et et il y a un moment où je me
suis dit tiens je vais parler des
cailloux parce que bah ça m'intéresse de
parler des cailloux il y a pas grand
monde qui en parle et puis c'est vrai
que quand j'en parle j'ai l'impression
de bah de parler avec la passion dont on
parlait tout à l'heure que j'avais pas
avant donc je me suis dit c'est bon
sujet je peux essayer de me décoincer
aussi m'enlever le bal que j'avais là où
je pense parce que j'étais c'était des
vidéos très sérieuses à l'époque et donc
là je me suis dit je comme ça deux
choses je choisis les cailloux et je
choisis de d'être drôle enfin d'essayer
en tout cas ouais et et c'est comme ça
que c'est parti j'ai fait ma première
deè non ma deème première vidéo sur
c'était sur pourquoi les géologues
lègent des cailloux qui a vraiment bien
marché pour le coup je me suis dit bon
bah c'est bon j'ai trouvé mon truc en
fait ça marche et et du coup j'ai
continué dans cette voie jusqu'à jusqu'à
aujourd'hui ok parce que être drôle du
coup c'est quelque chose enfin tu tu es
né avec ou c'est une compétence que tu
as développé très récemment
euh ê drôle ouais c'est difficile à dire
euh j'ai j'ai toujours eu pas mal
d'autodérision mais c'est un truc
familial en fait dans ma famille ils
sont tous très très très très drô rôle
vraiment mon père s'est fabriqué une
carte
d'humoriste il s'est plastifié enfin
bref chaque année il sen fait une du
coup parce que c'est valable qu'un an et
bref donc c'est vraiment un truc
familial d'être hyper hyper drôle je
pense que je suis la moins drôle de la
famille donc je suis quand même contente
que que les gens me trouvent drôle parce
que vraiment vous verriez mes cousins
vous verriez mes oncléantes enfin c'est
harant quoi les repas de famille on se
fait pipi dessus donc non non c'est
vraiment truc de famille à la fois
l'utérison OK et j'ai vu d'ailleurs dans
ton arrière-plan qu'il y avait des
figurines de South Park et je me suis
demandé si ça t'avait inspiré justement
dans tes touches humoristiques sur tes
vidéos absolument par je regarde depuis
très très longtemps c'est des figurines
de la génération 1 d'ailleurs elles sont
très très vieilles ok en fait je
regardais ça j'avais pas du tout là
j'avais largement moins de 10 ans et je
regardais ça avec mon frère la nuit
quand ça passait sur
Comédie je comprenais pas tout je
voulais juste regarder Kenny qui mourait
en fait ça ça me faisir voilà mais oui
je pense que ça a dû un peu un peu jouer
j'aimais beaucoup aussi happy tre
friendends ce genre de truc truc un peu
flash c'est un truc de famille Jackass
aussi c'était assez assez
fondateur genre de truc pe recommandable
quoi ouais je je vois bien et du coup tu
tu as l'air de toucher un peu à tout et
tu as l'air de toucher à tout très bien
même parce que tu fais des vidéos
extrêmement détaillé sur des sujets
qu'on peut parfois trouver très micro
que je moi je ne connaissais même pas
euh et du coup ouais je je voulais
savoir comment est-ce que toi tu quelles
sont un petit peu tes approches euh
pédagogiques d'apprentissage où est-ce
que tu t'informes est-ce que YouTube ça
fait partie justement de de tes canaux
d'information ou quels sont les quels
sont les médias un petit peu que tu
préfères alors c'est intéressant ça
YouTube euh est-ce que ça fait partie de
mes canaux pas tellement d'information
mais plutôt de veille donc je regarde
particulièrement comment une information
est traitée euh surtout si moi-même je
dois la traiter après parce que histoire
de pas refaire exactement la même chose
même si par hasard je savais pas que la
même chose était faite à côté je préfère
faire un peu une veille de ce qui s'est
dit sur tel sujet pour pouvoir me me
placer comme il faut quoi donc ça après
mes canaux d'information bah très
souvent ça commence par Wikipédia ça ne
finit pas par là évidemment c'est David
lo qui disait que Wikipédia c'est une
porte d'entrée et après il faut aller
fouiller dans les sources de Wikipédia
pour aller voir plus lo ce que j'utilise
beaucoup aussi c'est bah les sites pour
aller chercher dans des publications
scientifiques donc Google scolar euh et
d'autres mais c'est surtout scolar que
j'utilise ouais voilà ça euh les
bouquins académiques aussi ça fait un
moment que j'y suis pas allé mais il y a
un site euh qui n'est pas très légal que
je ne citerai pas qui permet d'obtenir
des des bouquins de chercheurs écrit par
les chercheurs pour les chercheurs en
anglais vraiment les pavés énormes là en
PDF et euh et ça j'ai beaucoup beaucoup
fouillé là-dedans parce que vraiment ça
te donne absolument toutes les
informations dont tu as besoin et dont
tu rêverais sur sur un sujet donné
particulièrement dans des trucs un peu
poussés en géologie vraiment des fois ça
part très très loin et et et c'est cool
parce que c'est pas juste lécher des C
ouais donc l'idée ouais c'est c'est un
peu de fouiller dans tout ce qui se dit
euh je fais pas trop au niveau de la
presse de enfin j'essaie vraiment de
remonter au sources primaires le plus
possible j'évite les sources secondaires
mais ça dépend du type d'information que
j'essaie de faire passer si c'est une
information vraiment académique Esser de
remonter au sources primaires parce que
c'est le plus important je trouve et
donc ça te ça te prend combien de temps
en général une vidéo je pense que ça
doit varier mais c'est et c'est une
partie que tu tu apprécies largement
aussi cette partie là alors j'ai j'ai
j'ai un amour mitigé pour la phase de
bibliographie le temps que ça me prend
c'est très variable quand vraiment je
vais fouiller très loin dans un sujet ça
peut me prendre un mois je pense en tout
un mois même juste pour la biblio ça
m'est arrivé alors c'est je dis que
c'est un amour mitigé parce que au début
j'ai une flemme immense de mettre
là-dedans vraiment la la biblio ça me
vraiment c'est dur mais une fois que j'y
suis et quand j'ai commencé à apprendre
des trucs je peux plus m'en sortir ou
vraiment c'est terrible je continue à
lire à lire à lire et je mets plein
d'infos de côté et limite je saute des
repas pour pouvoir continuer à lire mes
études scientifiques quoi parce que
c'est vraiment tout ou rien de mon côté
mais c'est vrai que avant d'arriver à ce
stade où euh je je je suis absorbée par
la littérature c'est
difficile c'est pour ça que mais c'est
important et et je trouve ça hyper
important aussi de d'arriver au stade
d'après qui est tu as emmagaziné toutes
les infos qu'il faut et là tu dois les
RE euh tu dois les digérer et les
ressortir d'une manière intelligente et
euh et ne pas te perdre dans les détails
et ça c'est la phase intelligente du
truc que j'aime bien particulièrement et
c'est là aussi tu peux trouver des
analogies des trucs comme ça pour faire
comprendre les choses vraiment la phase
euh mi éducative mi vulgarisationnelle
c'est ça qui m'intéresse dans le truc et
oui j'ai dit
vulgarisationnelle et à quel euh et à
quel moment euh
ton ta volonté de que la vidéo
fonctionne rentre en jeu et à quel point
euh ça justement euh ça rentre en jeu ou
est-ce que tu te dis d'abord j'ai envie
de faire quelque chose de qualitatif et
en plus qui euh qui soit
vulgaritionnellement vulgaris ellement
intéressant je l'ai tenté aussi
et il faut il faut et à quel point ces
deux ces deux aspects peuvent se mettre
ouais alors le le choix du sujet
n'arrive jamais euh dans attends je
recommence ma phrase dans le bon sens
quand je choisis mon sujet je pense
jamais à est-ce que ça va plaire ou pas
c'est vraiment est-ce que moi ça
m'intéresse de parler de ça et
particulièrement quand c'est des trucs
de niche euh ma dernière vidéo de
géologie c'était pour raconter
l'histoire la géologie des déserts genre
comment les dunes peuvent fossiliser et
tout enfin qui ça intéresse il y a
vraiment que moi que ça in mais c'est
justement le défi que je me suis posé
c'est d'essayer de rendre ça intéressant
et de piéger les gens à ce qu'il
regardent je sais pas 10 15 minutes de
la vidéo et après ils en ressortent en
disant mince mais j'étais pas du tout
parti pour regarder ça j'ai appris des
trucs qu'est-ce qui m'arrive donc c'est
plus ça le côté est-ce que ça marche ou
pas je l'arrête sur la forme plus que
sur le fond c'est-à-dire que c'est pour
ça que je mets des titres affreusement
plac des miniatures aussi enfin vraiment
je j'essaie d'enrober le trucs à fond
j'essaie de faire des mises en scène et
des trucs comme ça ça c'est le côté fun
et c'est le côté je vais essayer de de
piéger les gens pour qu'il cliquent et
qu' se rendent pas compte qu' qui
regardent de la géologie donc ça c'est
l'aspect qui m'intéresse on commençait à
parler de ta meilleure vidéo ouais tu as
dit téton quand même oui donc là je je
paris que c'est la plantation d'arbres
est-ce que j'ai
bon tu as bon c'est tout à fait juste
c'est ta vidéo la mieux noté euh alors
si je me trompe pas c'est la vidéo qui
est notée qui a une note de 48 donc
c'est une note extrêmement positive sur
tour le sol c'est pour le coup dans le
classement des meilleures
vidéos et donc cette vidéo a bah voilà
des scores positifs à peu près dans tous
les domaines important et actionnable
clair et pédagogique encourage de
meilleures habitudes c'est c'est le
critère sur lequel la vidéo est le mieux
noté est-ce que tu peux peut-être nous
parler un peu de de cette vidéo pourquoi
tu penses que c'est une vidéo qui est
particulièrement réussie comment est-ce
que comment est-ce que tu la vois euh
oui alors je pense que je suis quelqu'un
enfin de génial hein faut bien le dire
et du coup forcément cette vidéo est
granduse non pourquoi j'ai voulu parler
de ça ce sujet là c'est parce qu'en fait
c'était quand j'étais en cours de
biologie c'est un de mes profs qui enfin
une de mes prof je crois même euh qui
nous avait dit à quel point c'était
c'était complètement con cette histoire
de planter des arbres comme compensation
car bonne et j'avais aucune idée de ça
et vraiment c'est un moment où un moment
de réalisation pour moi en cours où je
me suis dit mais faut que tout le monde
sache ça en fait c'est trop important et
vraiment enfin tout le monde nous nous
le tartine au visage en mode même les
compagnies aériennes et tout vous
inquiétez pas prenez région on va
planter des arbres je me suis dit mais
non mais c'est trop grave et et ça
c'était il y a des années et plus ça va
plus ça va plus on l'entend partout il
compris notre cher président et donc
vraiment il y a un moment où j'en ai eu
marre le moment où j'en ai eu c'est
quand on m'a demandé de faire une sponso
pour euh un site je ne dirais pas lequel
je l' cité dans la vidéo d'ailleurs qui
dit acheter chez nous on plante des
arbres et et vraiment là je me suis dit
bon c'est trop après cette sponso je
l'ai faite évidemment j'ai je les ai
Vané là-dessus et et juste après je me
suis dit bon ben je fais la vidéo
là-dessus c'est vraiment trop trop
important et et j'ai fait cette vidéo et
je pense que bah j'espère qu'elle a bien
marché j'ai bossé dessus à fond niveau
biblio là parlons-en vraiment J a passé
c'est deux ou TR mois je crois ça ça se
voit ça se voit bien ah merci ah ça me
fait plaisir ouais parce que c'est c'est
un peu tendu comme sujet donc vraiment
je voulais faire les choses vraiment
vraiment bien je remercie le réveilleur
aussi qui qui a relu ma vidéo et tout
qui était plein de bons conseils ainsi
qu'un chercheur tir goklin dont j'avais
pas oublié le nom
voilà chercheur de limb à Marseille a
Marseille qui m'a aussi relu la vidéo
qui était plein de de bons conseils
aussi pour ça donc c'était enfin c tuit
un travail d'équipe donc c'était
vraiment très très chouette et je suis
contente qu'elle ait marché parce que
justement ça enfin ça véhicule un
message qui est important et et
régulièrement je la revois Popp même sur
Twitter et tout dès que dès qu'il y a un
nouveau phénomène de on plante des
arbres acheter chez nous et et ça ça me
fait extrêmement plaisir que ça devienne
un peu une vidéo référence parce que bah
parce que je me suis fait ché pour
mettre toutes les infos qu'il fallait
dedans et du coup je suis très contente
qu'elle puisse vivre et qu'elle estit
bien vécue aussi à l'époque non
franchement le travail est assez
impressionnant on sent que tu as passé
beaucoup de temps c'est super
détaillé du du coup est-ce que tu
pourrais peut-être rentrer un peu plus
en détail sur le message que tu as voulu
faire passer à travers cette vidéo ouais
alors le message c'est c'est un peu
toujours le même j'ai l'impression c'est
enfin quand on fait du du debunk c'est
de dire c'est plus compliqué que ça tout
simplement c'est planter des arbres
c'est pas forcément nécessairement mal
mais c'est pas nécessairement
merveilleux non plus c'est pas comme ça
qu'on va résoudre le changement
climatique quoi donc j'essayé un peu de
m'éloigner de cette vision simpliste et
complètement consumériste parce qu'il
faut bien dire en disant que enfin en
essayant de séparer le bien du mal et en
essayant de montrer un peu la complexité
du sujet puisquen écologie tout est
connecté et il y a des interactions
absolument partout donc tu peux pas
juste planter un arbre à un endroit en
disant tiens ça va faire du bien à
l'écosystème entier c'est pas comme ça
que ça marche il y a des spécificités ça
dépend de l'écosystème ça dépend du
climat ça dépend de d'absolument plein
plein plein de de variable que ce soit
chimique ou même politique faut bien
dire et et social et et du coup c'é
important pour moi de mettre en avant ça
et j'ai oublié ta question je me rends
compte ouais c'était non c'était sur le
message global que tu voulais faire
passer à travers cette vidéo et comme il
y a énormément de de sujets dans la
vidéo ça peut être un exercice difficile
oui voilà non le le message global c'est
de dire c'est plus compliqué que ça on
va pas sauver le climat en plantant des
arbres ouais et ncoutez pas les gens qui
vous disent ça mais tout en gardant le
petit bémol du planter des arbres c'est
pas forcément mauvais non plus si c'est
bien fait et voilà donc j'avais à cœur
de mettre à la fin de la vidéo les bons
critères auquel il fallait faire
attention si on voulait planter des
arbres de la bonne manière si vraiment
on insistait pour planter des AR est-ce
que ça répond à ta question je pourrais
difficilement faire plus court que ça je
pense ça répond très bien à la question
et je me
demandais si planter des
arbres c'était une solution qui
appartenait au champ
euh au champ obscur de la géoingénierie
je
dirais alors c'est une très bonne
question j'ai prévu de faire une vidéo
sur la
géoingénierie mais je l'ai pas commencé
du coup je saurais pas te répondre plus
que ça ouais ça ça rejoint l'état
d'esprit effectivement mais je sais pas
si ça si ça rentre dans cette catégorie
là ok ça marche
euh j'ai trouvé ça aussi vachement
intéressant ta vidéo et ça ça me
conforte dans un un sentiment que j' de
plus en plus euh c'est qu'en fait on a
souvent l'impression que les progrès
scientifiques humains sont
impressionnant et qu'on crée des
machines à calculer absolument
gigantesques et et que du coup on a une
forme de on a une forme de de toute
puissance à travers ces outils
extrêmement sophistiqués et en fait plus
le temps passe et plus j'apprends des
choses sur le fonctionnement de la
nature et plus je réalise à quel point
elle est complexe et du coup le
sentiment que j'ai c'est que euh quand
on essae en fait d'agir sur la nature on
se confronte à une complexité qui est
telle que il y a très souvent des effets
imprévisible
euh et du coup bah je me demande si tu
voulais si tu pouvais peut-être un peu
parler de ça de cette confrontation un
petit peu entre la volonté de l'homme
d'agir et deif modifier l'environnement
et la complexité de la nature qui est
telle que en fait nos actions ont
tendance à créer des des effets
imprévisibles
ouis tout à fait je suis absolument
d'accord avec toi il y a un exemple
assez marrant je trouve c'est tout ce
qui touche au biomimétisme ouais genre
on se dit on va imiter les les pâtes du
gecko enfin du Geko pour faire un un
revêtement quité en mur ce genre de truc
et en fait vraiment on se base sur des
détails pour les exploiter ailleurs mais
la nature c'est pas des détails c'est
des interactions c'est plein de trucs
qui se mélangent et de la pardon c'est
pas très clair ce que je suis en train
de dire là je je par en mode gourou mais
c'est imaginons on a un écosystème et on
a telle espèce de plante dedans qui
stock très bien le carbone et on se dit
bah super on va faire une monoculture
sur des hectares et des hectares de
cette cette plante là et là on se rend
compte qu'en fait elle stock moins bien
le carbone que ce qu'on pense parce
qu'en fait c'est pas une histoire de
juste cette plante là c'est une histoire
de cette plante dans ce sol là qui
contient ces micoris donc c'est ces
communautés de champignons on va dire et
cette espèce elle est pas toute seule
non plus elle est en en enfin c'est un
assemblage d'espèces et donc en fait
c'est justement le carbone qui peut
circuler d'une espèce à l'autre et dans
les champignons et puis ressortir
ailleurs ou je sais pas quoi et en fait
c'est c'est justement quand on essaie de
reproduire quelque chose qu'on se rend
compte à quel point tous les facteurs
qui sont impliqués là-dedans sont
vraiment complètement interconnectés et
c'est extrêmement difficile de vouloir
reproduire quelque chose aussi bien que
la nature l'a déjà fait tout simplement
parce que l'évolution ça fait des
millions d'années qu'elle y est et que
nous on débarque juste quoi et on
découvre on n pas la notice quoi donc au
fur à mesure on fait du du rétro
inéering pour pour y arriver ouais
complètement et d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant parce que au-delà justement
des effets que des effets imprévisible
qu' peut y avoir justement sur la nature
sur la biodiversité dans cette vidéo tu
parles aussi de du volet euh social
justement du de la plantation d'arbres
et euh de l'augmentation des inégalités
sociales que ça peut engendrer euh et
notamment euh bah des choses auxquelles
on pense pas naturellement quand on
pense à planter des arbres mais à des
déplacements par exemple de population
absolument c'est un truc auquel j'avais
pas spécialement réfléchi avant de
commencer à à me documenter là-dessus et
effectivement en fait c'est une énorme
dimension politique derrière de se dire
que enfin même géopolitique de se dire
que c'est les pays pauvres qui prennent
encore une fois pour les pays riches et
les pays riches qui s'en sortent juste
en payant donc c'est un peu terrible que
enfin c'est vraiment la double peine
pour les pays pauvres quoi et c'est bien
de garder ça en tête et c'est bien
justement que que les riches soient au
courant de ce qui se passe quand ils
achètent un café et qu' veulent planter
un arbre en fait il il se passe des
horreurs derrière il se passe des
expropriations il se passe de la
déforestation pour pouvoir planter son
petit arbre enfin c'est des nonsens mais
il faut en parler parce que sinon ça va
continuer quoi
ouais et du coup qu'est-ce que ouais et
et du coup pour continuer sur la
dynamique Elise Luet qu'est-ce que tu
penses qu'est-ce que tu penses de la
proposition justement de Macron de
planter des arbres il me semble c'est
quoi en école primaire c'est ça oui oui
oui c'est c'est quoi c'est chaque élève
doit planter un arbre un truc comme ça
ouais écoute c'est symbolique euh après
sur sa proposition particulier je me
prononcerai pas parce que j'ai pas j'ai
pas j'ai pas été fouillé mais
euh je pense que c'est plus symbolique
qu'autre chose après en France il faut
savoir que ce que ce que je déplore avec
le fait de planter des arbres c'est
qu'on les plante n'importe comment
n'importe où or en France on est quand
même dans un climat tempéré où a priori
il y a quand même énormément de forêts
des forêts qui sont plantées de base
mais des forêts quand même et du coup si
on les plante là où il y a déjà des
arbres ou là où c'était c'est un endroit
déforesté mais qui était qui avait un
couvert forestier il y a moins de
quelques siècles c'est pas complètement
con
ouais après il faut voir dans le détail
comment c'est fait et tout donc je je
sais pas pour pour cette affaire je me
prononcerai pas on pourrait dire ça fait
écho une vidéo qu' qu'on avait fait avec
écologie rationnelle qui disait ce qui
est vrai à un endroit n'est pas
forcément vrai à are endroit notamment
en écologie donc euh peut-être que nous
ce serait une bonne idée mais peut-être
pas que tous les pays du monde doivent
s'inspirer de de cette
idée réfléchir un peu aux conséquences
oui oui ça c'est sûr et puis ça dépend
quel espèce il plante aussi enfin je je
sais pas du tout je me suis pas
renseigné là-dessus mais euh j'espère
que lui il s'est renseigné avant de
faire son
truc super euh petitouon est-ce que tu
veux peut-être qu'on passe à la deuxième
vidéo
euh ouais avec
plaisir que je me
remette en
tête le sujet ouais bah alors moi je je
la la la deuxième vidéo sur laquelle je
suis tombé sur tournol en taper en
tapant ton nom c'était pas elle était
pas directement elle provenait pas
directement de ta chaîne mais elle pr
elle provenait de la
chaîne correcte-moi si corrige-moi si je
me me trompe info ou infox info ou mytho
info ou mytho pardon info ou mytho ah je
savais pas qu'ils étaient chez vous et
je et si ces vidéos ont été notées euh
et c'est et c'était la vidéo sur la
cigarette ah oui
ouais
euh et je trouve bah je l'ai trouvé
hyper intéressante il y avait des
références que moi j'aime bien qui
m'intéresse beaucoup euh et qu'on
pourrait d'ailleurs tout à fait creuser
notamment des personnages comme edard
berneis euh mais du coup qu'est-ce qui
t'a qu'est-ce qui t'a poussé à faire une
vidéo dessus est-ce que c'était une
vidéo que tu as décidé de faire seul
est-ce que c'était en équipe et pourquoi
ce sujet alors c'est une vidéo qu'on a
choisi en équipe donc il y a toute
l'équipe de d'info Myo on est 5 ou si et
et en fait c'est eux qui choisissent les
sujets qui me les proposent et moi je
dis bingo ou pas et et en fait
d'habitude on traitait des théories du
complot donc vraiment est-ce que les les
les aliens ont construit des pyramides
enfin ce genre de truc la zone 51 c'est
assez facile à débunkerer et et on s'est
dit c'est bien mignon mais en même temps
c'est pas pour autant qu'il y a pas de
complot sur cette terre et on voulait un
peu prendre le contrepied de ce qu'on
faisait nous-même en se disant on va
traiter d'un vrai complot ouais et le
complot des cigaretiers c'est un peu un
cas d'école ce truc et du coup ça ça
nous tenait à cœur de traiter ce truc
notamment que c'est une chaîne qui
s'adresse aux adolescents les
adolescents enfin qui commencent à être
un peu rebelles à se dire tiens je vais
commencer à fumer tout ça enfin bref et
et du coup on s'est dit que c'était une
bonne idée de traiter de ce sujet là et
enfin c'est eux qui se sont dit et moi
je je lesai rejoints pour le coup et
encore une fois c'est en documentant que
j'ai appris toutes ces horreurs et
notamment c'est complètement idiot mais
ça m'a encore marqué cette histoire
l'histoire des cigarettes en chocolat
qu'on avait quand on était petit enfin
je sais pas si vous vous aviez ça oui
moi je de temps en temps quand c
lawingum euh pas en chocolat mais c'est
un peu le même nous on avait en
chewingum après ah c'est pas mal ben je
connaissais pas ça moi j'avais la
version au chocolat et en plus le
chocolat était pas bon mais c'était la
fête quand quand quand on nous achetait
ça c'était vendu genre dans les
marchands de journaux les kiosques tabac
et ces trucs là et vraiment c'était la
fête pour moi de pouvoir manger ces
trucs là et et en fait ça aussi c'était
ça faisait partie du lobby enfin d'un de
la stratégie du lobby des cigaretiers
pour habituer les enfants à avoir les
mêmes gestes que les adultes pour fumer
ce genre de chose c'est ouf ouais donc
c'est pas du tout une c'est pas juste un
bout de chocolat quoi ça m'a un peu
refroidi de enfin voilà donc j'ai pris
plein plein de choses je je je sais pas
si d'ailleurs pour cette vidéo tu tis
appuyé sur en partie sur le livre les
marchands de dout ou si ça te dit
quelque chose ouais
eu bah j'avais lu ce bouquin il y a
quelques années je l'avais trouvé
vraiment passionnant et du coup c'est un
bouquin qui notamment montrait comment
c'est les que c'est les mêmes personnes
qui en fait SEM le doute sur la réalité
du réchauffement climatique qui avait
SEM le doute sur les danger du tabac
oui ouais euh donc c'était vachement
intéressant et c'est aussi je
trouve les la grande industrie du tabac
on va dire que en terme de en terme de
lobbying et de stratégie commerciale il
y a beaucoup de on va dire de de
comparaisons à établir avec la stratégie
qu'utilisent les réseaux sociaux aussi
euh bah notamment par exemple bah tu en
parles dans ta vidéo le fait de viser
justement des publics très jeunes parce
que il représente en fait des
consommateurs des consommateurs de toute
une vie
eu c'est justement bah une des grandes
stratégies qu'on quiessayent de mettre
en place les réseaux sociaux même si ils
ont du mal parce qu'évidemment l'opinion
publique les tient un petit peu
justement à l'œil évidemment les énormes
justement bah dépenses de lobbying
auprès notamment des politiciens
américain ce fut le cas pour Big tobaco
notamment dans les années 90 h euh aux
États-Unis eu aujourd'hui c'est
effectivement les réseaux sociaux euh
mais il y a il je trouve qu'il y a il y
a un truc avec les réseaux sociaux qui
les rend limite encore plus dangereux
dans leur euh dans leur volonté de ne
pas être régulé et de continuer
justement à s'étendre c'est que là où en
fait euh le Big tabaco peut euh en gros
bah un peu bah donner de l'argent au
politiciens américains les réseaux
sociaux font la même chose mais ce
qu'ils ont en plus c'est que les réseaux
sociaux ont cet effet polarisant et donc
en fait euh les réseaux sociaux divisent
en soi la classe politique qui ont du
coup de plus en plus de eux-mêmes du mal
à se mettre d'accord pour réguler les
réseaux sociaux parce qu'ils sont
polarisés par ces mêmes outilsl et donc
c'est et c'est donc c'est là où c'est là
où les réseaux sociaux justement ont
cette particularité là que non seulement
ils arrivent à faire du lobbying
classique mais en plus de ça le
caractère polarisé de ces plateformes
fait que c'est encore plus difficile en
fait de trouver des accords donc ouais
je trouvais ça assez intéressant
ouais c'est intéressant surtout avec S
qui vient d'arriver et qui se dit au
contraire enfin étanche à tous les enfin
au militantisme et compagnie qui vaut au
contraire être dans la bienveillance et
compagnie je me demande ce que ça va
donner tout ça ouais ça ça va être ouais
ça va être intéressant à
suivre il y avait il y avait un exemple
de ça quand franis Haugen avait qui éit
une ex une ex salarié de Facebook avait
dévoilé les face les Facebook files donc
des documents internes qui montraient
que meta était au courant de tous les
les problèmes que ces plateformes
posaient à la santé mentale des jeunes
notamment et cetera et cetera h euh et
ben à ce moment-là euh en fait elle
devait rencontrer des élus républicains
bah pour parler de régulation des
réseaux sociaux et un élu républicain
avait refusé de l'avir parce qu'en fait
il était mis sous pression par plein
d'autres politiciens républicains qui en
fait avaient vu des fausses formation
sur franis Hogan notamment sur Facebook
comme quoi elle était un agent infiltré
des démocrates euh et et donc bah ça
avait stoppé en fait toute la discussion
avec les politiciens républicains donc
en fait ça avait complètement freiné euh
freiné tout le processus de régulation
quoi comme
quoi donc en parallèle de de régulation
il y a il y a aussi euh justement
l'importance des du de ce combat euh
pour les jeunes il y a par exemple
l'application TikTok donc euh baptisé de
Win en en Chine qui est limité à 40
minutes par jour chez les moins de 14
ans donc euh on voit bien ce cet
équilibre là où où il y a les réseaux
sociaux qui sont vraiment diffusé enfin
notamment TikTok qui est diffusé à
l'international vraiment largement et au
sein de leur propre leur propre pays la
Chine le les restreint au aux plus
jeunes conscient sement des des
conséquences que ça pourrait avoir sur
leur population
ouais ouais c'est intéressant
complètement et toi c'est un c'est un
sujet aussi que tu creuses de ton côté
euh bah tout ce qui concerne notre
rapport à l'information l'impact des
algorithmes sur notre capacité un peu à
faire sens du monde euh bah un petit peu
je j'en avais traité un petit peu avec
un chercheur qui est allemand et qui est
spécialiste justement de des fausses
informations sur Youtube ce genre de
truc OK et euh et c'est vrai que c'est
intéressant mais il faudrait que je me
tienne au courant c'était au moment des
Facebook files il me semble ok donc ça
pour le coup j'avais à peu près suivi
mais j'ai complètement lâché et ça me
déprime un peu mais il faudrait pas mais
ouais mais il faut faut que je me
renseigne il faut que j'arrête de passer
4h par J par jour sur
TikTok tu tu utilises TikTok justement
ouais j'utilise TikTok ouais je j'ai
honte mais c'est terrible quand c'est un
peu ton métier les réseaux sociaux parce
que du coup tu peux pas vraiment te
comment comment tu fais dans ce genre de
cas pour avoir une bonne hygiène de vie
ouais bah justement bah c'est une
question hyper intéressante je me pose
la question
aussi de comment en fait tu fais pour
être actif sur les réseaux sociaux et
essayer de donner de la visibilité au
messages que que tu portes sans tomber
addicte pour moi ça revient un peu à
résoudre la question comment est-ce que
tu utilises une drogue tous les jours
sans devenir addicte ce qui me semble un
peu compliqué mais toi quel est ton ton
ressenti là-dessus est-ce que tu as
pression du coup un petit peu de mettre
le doigt dans l'engrenage et d'avoir
d'avoir un peu cet effet addictif quand
tu passes sur les réseaux bah plus trop
alors c'est vrai il a évidemment le choc
de de dopamine quand tu reçois des likes
et des trucs comme ça ça c'est
indéniable c'est conçu pour mais après
j'essaie de garder pas mal de recul face
à tout ça euh je sais qu'il y a des fois
où vraiment ça ça ça a pu me faire du
mal au cerveau et j'ai pu faire des
pauses de réseaux sociaux ça m'est
arrivé ouais mais bon je le signalais
pas spécialement et je revenais après et
personne n'ait vu que j'étais parti donc
en fait on en fait tout un fois mais
faut pas hésiter à prendre des pauses
quoi c'est important ouais et euh et je
plus où j'allais avec cette phrase mais
c'est bien
déjà c'est déjà pas mal
et c'est quoi le le canal qui te qui toi
te semble le plus pertinent justement
pour communiquer auprès de ta communauté
enfin où est-ce qu'elle se trouve
globalement ta communauté je saurais pas
te dire
bah j'ai envie de dire historiquement
c'est plutôt Twitter parce que de base
au tout tout tout début j'ai ouvert mon
blog et j'ai ouvert Twitter en même
temps donc ça date de 2013 quoi j'ai
j'ai une vieille communauté sur Twitter
mais c'est vrai que depuis que tout le
monde s'en va de Twitter et a raison je
sais pas trop je sais pas trop comment
comment m'adapter effectivement donc
j'essaie un peu un peu partout mais
c'est pas évident un peu un peu
Instagram aussi un peu YouTube l'onglet
communauté mais bon vraiment c'est pas
c'est pas évident je suis en train de
d'essayer de trouver mes marques ouais h
h
ou il y a cette cette diversité aussi
maintenant il y en a énormément qui ont
chacun un peu leur leur spécialités et
euh moi j'avais à petite échelle créer
justement du contenu sur Instagram et
TikTok je me suis rendu compte de la de
la
viralité de de certains contenus euh j'y
passais vraiment très peu de temps à les
créer il y a eu parfois des des millions
de vues mais c'était vraiment les les
contenus souvent les plus vraiment les
plus polarisés qui qui partai en en
millions de vues tandis que les les
contenus un peu posés un peu un peu
pertinent même s'ils étaient drôles même
s'ils étaient punchy il y avait oui j'ai
utilisé le mot
punchy et il y avait il y avait beaucoup
moins cette cette viralité là moi je moi
j'ai par exemple pour parler de mon
expérience personnelle j'ai j'ai
complètement arrêté euh euh Instagram j
passais beaucoup de temps et j'ai
désactivé l'algorithme de recommandation
de YouTube donc maintenant il y a sur
Youtube et sur l'application et sur et
sur
euh l'ordinateur j'ai plus l'algorithme
de recommandation de YouTube donc c'est
soit les vidéos où je suis abonné soit
quand je fais des recherches par
moi-même soit l'algorithme de
recommandation de de tournesol et euh ça
ça m'a drastiquement réduit mon mon
temps sur Youtube et j'ai senti une une
grande amélioration aussi dans dans ce
que je regardais et euh et après l'autre
point moi je trouve que aussi il y a le
réseau social Mastodon que j'ai étudié
en cours euh euh j'ai fait un projet sur
les sur les médias sociaux et c'est vrai
qu' une des grandes un des grands atouts
c'est que il est est décentralisé et
donc il y a pas une personne qui ou un
groupe de personnes qui a le monopole de
la recommandation qui a le monopole de
de comment les échanges se passent si à
un moment on sent pas on se sent pas
dans son élément sur le sur le serveur
sur lequel on est on peut on a
simplement à à changer de serveur et si
on trouve aucun serveur qui qui nous
convient il y en a plusieurs milliers
donc normalement on a on a ce qu'il faut
mais on peut même aussi créer son
serveur et et c'est vrai que ça c'est
c'est assez intéressant notamment en
terme de de résilience si si
demain Twitter ferme je sais pas combien
il y a de personnes qui vivent grâce à
Twitter ou qui sont connu grâce à
Twitter ou qui ou qui échange seulement
grâce à Twitter mais donc s'il y a un
serveur qui est plutôt décentralisé il y
a quand même plus de résilience sur ces
aspects
là complètement
petit je sais pas si tu voulais passer
sur bah l'autre vidéo en fait du coup ça
fait une troisème vidéo portait sur qui
était la mieux notée portait sur
l'éolien en mer et ouais c'est elle est
notée 41 donc elle est en haut du
classement 55 comparaisons par 21
contributeurs et elle est notée
fortement sur le notamment sur le
critère stimulant et suscite la
réflexion BB
ouais est-ce que tu tu tu peux nous
parler peut-être un petit peu de cette
vidéo comment çaéit venu cette cette
idée ouais ouais tout à fait alors
c'était une vidéo en fait c'était une
collab avec le réveilleur encore lui et
Monsieur bidouille et en fait on a été
contacté par une entité c'est le la
Commission nationale du débat public euh
autour de l'implantation enfin c un
débat autour de l'implantation des d'un
champ offshore d'éolienne au large de la
nouvelle kitaine ouais et du coup ils
nous ont contacté tous les trois en
disant est-ce que vous voudriez faire
des vidéos donc c'était une commande euh
pour nous chacun en développant un
aspects différents et donc le réveilleur
a fait l'aspect en général climatique
énergie ouais monsieur bidouille
c'estéit aspect technique et moi je me
suis occupé de l'aspect impact
environnemental impact sur les
écosystèmes en particulier vraiment de
l'implantation des éoliennes donc
l'impact local
et et ça m'a vachement intéressé parce
que je connaissais pas du tout ce
sujetlà et euh pour changer et euh
vraiment c'était c'était hyper chouette
pareil je me suis plongée dans des
études à n'en pas finir j'ai passé
énormément enfin des mois encore une
fois sur la biblio et et vraiment encore
une fois j'ai étis complètement happé et
c'était hyper intéressant quoi ne
serait-ce que de pouvoir parce que là du
coup c'était je comparais des études
local sur différents champs d'éolienne
et puis après j'essayé de regarder s'il
y avait des des métaanalyses enfin des
des revues la littérature des trucs
comme ça sur le sujet mais en général
pas vraiment donc fallait prendre des
trucs locaux et limite c'était presque
au stade de chercheur ce que je faisais
quoi OK donc c'était hyper intéressant
et en plus on avait des des chercheurs
qui qui étaient à notre disposition pour
nous filer un coup de main aussi pour
nous filer des de la biblio tout ça donc
c'était vraiment vraiment cool de
pouvoir bosser sur ce sujet et en
sortant de cette vidéo j'étais hyper
satisfaite et je me suis dit ça me donne
envie de faire la même chose de regarder
l'impact environnemental de tous les
différents modes enfin de production
d'énergie ce que je n'ai absolument pas
fait mais ouais mais ça reste un projet
dans le coin de ma tête et je crois que
la vidéo a été tu assez bien reçu aussi
au-delà de de tournesol sauf mon humour
qui est pas forcément très bien passé
mais c'est vrai quand les gens viennent
de d'autres communautés c'est ça peut
faire un choc je comprends je c je crois
que c'est sur celle-là où tu poussais le
bouchon assez loin au niveau de l'humour
notamment dans tes roquettes pour
abonnement c'est vrai j'ai
oublié mais j'ai j'en ai énervé
quelquesuns j'ai j'ai trouvé ça très
bien joué et ce que j'ai trouvé aussi
très bien joué c'est ta capacité à
mettre des photos qui sont comment on
appelle ça déjà les images que tu utiles
exactement les photo stock et ça je
trouve que c'est un c'est un coup de
génie merci merci mais non mais ça c'est
terrible parce qu'en fait cétait un
projet à TR et pour une fois j'avais
fini un peu en avance ce qui n'arrive
jamais et et du coup j'ai passé plus de
temps enfin j'avais du temps à perdre
sur mon montage et du coup j'ai rajouté
plein plein de conneries et et c'est là
où j'aurais peut-être pas dû enfin si
j'aurais dû ça m'a fait beaucoup rire
mais c'est pour ça qu'il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de blagues dans le dans le
montage de cette vidéo
trop bien et moi benah encore une fois
vraiment j'ai j'ai j'ai adoré la vidéo
et est-ce que assez euh assez rapidement
peut-être tu pourrais euh nous parler un
peu de son contenu et notamment bah
toujours dans dans ce dans cette dans ce
truc un peu de bah voilà on a
l'impression que finalement c'est simple
de mettre des de l'éolien en mer et euh
euh que tout ça est logique et en fait
bah quand on regarde ta vidéo et le
travail que tu fournis on voit
évidemment que il y a plein de
complexités qu'on prend pas en compte
que ce soit du bon ou du mauvais
d'ailleurs ouais c'est ça après je me
souviens plus en détail mais comme tu
dis encore une fois le sujet c'est c'est
plus compliqué que ça parce qu'il y a
une une forte aversion aux éoliennes ça
aussi j'ai c'est c'est un sujet en soi
j'ai un peu bossé dessus et et c'est pas
Terri dans la vidéo ça vait rien à y
[__] mais c'est un super sujet de se
dire les éoliennes il y a l'effet c'est
super mais pas pas dans mon jardin quoi
ouais et ça c'est c'est j'ai
l'impression enfin j'avais cru voir que
la la réception je sais plus comment on
dit exactement mais la réception du
public au
nouvelles énergies je vais me faire
taper dessus par le réveilleur je sais
comment on dit et en général pas très
bonne et c'est assez intéressant de voir
ça et ouais donc il y a le côté
leséoliennes Bou et caca ça tue les
chauv-souris et c'est assez rigolo de
voir que en mer c'est pas du tout la
même chose que sur terre déjà parce que
déjà il y a pas de côté usage des terres
et compagnie il y a pas de côté bah
c'est des zones qui sont sinistrées du
coup on peut pas pêcher c'est pas vrai
il y a des couloirs de pêche à
l'intérieur euh et puis en fait il y a
un truc complètement contreintuitif qui
est de se dire en fait quand on met une
ééolienne en mer on crée un obstacle on
crée un je sais plus comment ça
s'appelle un récif voilà un récif ouais
je crois que c'est ça crée un effet réif
et en fait ça ça va créer la de
l'hétérogénéité dans le milieu et du
coup ça va susciter euh bah l'arrivée de
de bestioles et donc d'abord des petites
bestioles puis des plus grosses
bestioles qui vont manger les petites et
en fait tu as tout un écosystème qui se
met en place autour des pieds d'éolienes
et donc finalement c'est bénéfique pour
la biodiversité on dirait pas comme ça
et je franchement je trouvais ça gros au
début moi j'étais parti j'avais accepté
ce truc là en disant bon je vais
défoncer les olers et en fait j'ai rien
eu à défoncer parce que enfin l'effet
réif il est quand même très positif il
est documenté depuis je sais pas 20 30
ans un truc comme ça facile
et donc voilà il est acquis et au début
je trouvais ça gros je me suis dit non
mais c'est une histoire des lobby encore
et en fait j'ai creusé j'ai creusé et
non bah il est avéré c'est c'est dans la
littérature c'est c'est vrai euh donc
c'est assez intéressant de voir qu'en
fait il y a pas que du négatif autour de
ça alors effectivement il y a des
aspects négatifs de bruit de notamment
au moment des des travaux ça fait des
énormes pollutions sonores pour les pour
les bestioles marines dont notamment les
mamifères marins qui s'appuient beaucoup
sur sur Louis pour se déplacer et tout
et tout leur sonard machin mais il y a
pas que du mauvais et du coup c'était
intéressant j'ai trouvé de faire une
vidéoù il y avait pas que du mauvais
parce que une vidéo d'écologie qui soit
pas négative c'est rare et du coup c'est
pr
précieux clairement et d'ailleurs un des
un des exemples qui est intéressant pour
montrer que justement bah des des objets
fin des objets humains des constructions
humaines qui sont perdues dans la nature
peuvent finalement avoir des effets
positifs positif c'est les les vestiges
de sous-marins par exemple
oui alors je sais pas si sous-marin
c'était très malin mais comme choix de
mot non ça va il y a prescription euh
oui oui effectivement toutes les épaves
et tout enfin les plongeurs le savent tu
vas plonger au niveau des épaves parce
que c'est là où tu auras plein de
bestioles à voir et c'est hyper
important et il y a même un truc qui est
interdit en pêche c'est de mettre un un
radeau je sais plus comment ça s'appelle
mais tu mets un obstacle en hauteur ou
et du coup les poissons viennent autour
et toi tu as plus qu'à ramasser et ça je
crois que c'est plus ou moins interdit
en tout cas à un moment ça a été
interdit peut-être dans certaines
conditions je sais plus mais étude
remonte un peu là-dedans mais oui oui le
fait de mettre des des obstacles ou des
objets en mer ça fait venir les les
poissons ouais et ça peut leur plaire du
coup enfin là en l'occurrence pour le le
côté réif ils ont de quoi se fixer en
plus donc ça fait des écosystème qui
reste et qui et qui peuvent
s'épanouir magnifique
euh une petite info en plus que mes que
mes révisions d'examen n'ont pas servi à
rien je j'ai justement eu un examen
aujourd'hui sur les les sources
d'énergie et euh j'avais vu un très
intéressant le schéma je le mettrai en
en commentaire du Global Wind Energy
Council qui avait
euh réfléchi sur les euh challenges
transversaux que pouvait avoir le
l'énergie éolienne pour se développé et
euh du coup à à 10 ans le les challenges
les plus importants qu'ils avaient
repéré c'était justement la social
acceptance donc l'acceptation sociale et
l'utilisation des des terres donc pour
les pour les éoliens onshore
mais mais du coup très intéressant ce
schéma et on et on se rend compte que
que il y a des personnes qui ont même
réfléchi à tous ces à tous ces aspects
là euh et ça donne ça donne des petit
peu de réflexion
ouais c'est hyper intéressant c'est
marrant de se dire que la tour effelle
il y a des millions de gens qui viennent
la voir chaque année bon des millions
j'invente mais une éolienne c'est Bou
c'est caca c'est c'est rigolo quand même
quand on je pense à méditer à méditer
rendons les les éoliennes aussi
attractif que la T
exactement met une éolien sur la
tour ouais est-ce que on passe peut-être
aux
vidéos au vidéos qui ne sont pas des
vidéos de ta chaîne mais que tu as
recommandé notamment la vidéo sur le
fond qui concerne le glyphosate ça vous
va avec grand plaisir alors la question
sera très simple pourquoi ce ce choix
est-ce que tu peux nous parler un petit
peu de cette vidéo absolument c'est une
vidéo de mon compère Pierre Girard que
j'aime beaucoup c'est un journaliste
scientifique qui bosse pour é notamment
et qui a une chaîne qui est spécialisée
dans l'agriculture et notamment il
regarde tout ce qui est
bah des solutions innovantes pour
l'agriculture mais innovant en mode
agriculture de conservation ce genre de
truc et il va voir directement les
agriculteurs partout sur leur champ et
ça peut être même à l'étranger et tout
et c'est vraiment vraiment bien ce qu'il
fait c'est un un très bon travail de
journaliste et de terrain et et là c'est
une vidéo qu'il a faite sur le
glyphosate et il va voir justement bah
une petite exploitation et une grande
exploitation qui utilise le glyphosate
et notamment une qui est en justement on
disait en agriculture de conservation et
ça répond très bien justement au au à la
phrase bah c'est plus compliqué que ça
parce que on a souvent en tête
l'opposition glyphosate c'est pour les
grandes enfin les les monocultures
intensives et de l'autre côté au
contraire euh les tout ce qui est bio
euh enfin respectueux l'environnement et
compagnie qui utilise rien du tout et là
on se rend compte qu'en fait bah ce
genre de d'exploitation le deuxème cas
peut utiliser aussi du glyphosate et
donc ça permet de voir un peu la
complexité du truc et de dire si on
l'interdit qu'est-ce qu'on fait est-ce
qu'il y a des alternatives sur quoi
bossent les cherchurs en ce moment pour
le remplacer est-ce que c'est faisable
enfin voilà ça ça fait le point un peu
sur tout ça et c'est un sujet qui est
quand même extrêmement sensible et
d'actualité et de société aussi et euh
et je trouve qu' il fait vraiment un
excellent travail et euh
particulièrement sur cette vidéo qui est
sortie il y a 2 semaines je crois et du
coup je vous encourage à aller la voir
qu'elle est bien elle est bien notée sur
tourne sol ah
elle a seulement trois contributeur elle
est déjà à 18 donc pas assez pour être
recommandé sur ton OL mais euh déjà très
bien doté euh ben allez me noter ça
allez me noter allons noter ça
d'ailleurs je rappelle aux personnes qui
qui regardent le live et qui suivent un
peu tournol que si vous si vous faites
10 comparaisons au moins 10 comparaisons
par semaine pendant tout le mois de vous
plantez un arbre de décembre non encore
mieux vous coupez des arbres parce que
parce que il y a l' de science for all
qui s'est engagé à envoyer 10 livres par
tirage au
sort donc mais l'information parfois
nécessite un petit peu de de de
ressources on le voit aussi avec ce ce
live qui peut consommer un petit peu
d'énergie mais si le si l'information
est plus bénéfique que l'énergie qu'elle
consomme ça peut ça peut avoir des
effets positif mais en tout cas
n'hésitez pas à à à comparer les vidéos
sur tournosol en ce mois de décembre
vous pourriez avoir sous votre sapin un
peu en retard un un livre dédicacé de de
lait oh la classe
oh et euh moi j'avais beaucoup aussi
aimé cette vidéo je me posais une
question un peu en général sur sur
justement on se rend compte ah c'est pas
si c'est pas si facile que ça on se rend
compte quand même sur beaucoup de tes
vidéos et et aussi sur beaucoup de
vidéos de tournosol en général
euh mais comment on peut faire aussi un
petit peu quand on quand on est pas
forcément
cette cette capacité ou cette force à
toujours pousser pousser le bouchon et à
pas et à pas avoir forcément des des
solutions faciles qu'on pourrait un peu
lâcher comme ça est-ce que on juste on
accepte que il y a pas de solution
facile et et ça doit faire partie de
notre de notre quotidien ou est-ce que
on on aurait pas aussi un peu tendance à
se dire bon ben quand même on peut être
on peut promouvoir de planter des arbres
et de et et de pas utiliser le
glyphosate ça serait quand même un petit
peu plus un petit peu plus facile pour
mon quotidien qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que tu en penses de d'un peu cette cette
équilibre entre complexité et
et et et et quand même santé mentale
peut-être un petit
peu bah perso j'en pense que j'aime pas
trop donner des aux gens j'aime bien
leur donner les cartes pour que eux
fassent le choix de de leur choix qu'
veulent mais de base j'aime pas dire aux
gens quoi faire euh donc je pense que si
si quelqu'un veut conseiller de planter
des arbres voir planter des arbres chez
lui ou ou au Burkina Faso grand bien lui
fasse mais j'aime bien que les gens
puissent avoir un avis enfin s'ils ont
un avis qu's a un avis éclairé pour ma
part je prône le fait de ne pas avoir
d'avis c'est quand même quelque chose de
relativement rare peut-être qu'on a
perdu l'habitude avec Twitter aussi mais
mais c'est aussi très bien de pas avoir
d'avis et de pas vouloir se prononcer
sur un sujet par exemple le glyphosate
je ne me prononcerai pas dessus pourtant
dans mes études j'ai fait un an en école
d'agronomie et tout donc je je devrais
pouvoir mais je me prononce pas parce
que j'estime que j'ai pas assez
d'information pour pouvoir prendre une
une décision éclairée enfin là-dessus
avoir une opinion éclairée là-dessus
donc voilà je pense que le fait de ne
pas avoir d'avis c'est quand même
vachement bien et je pense aussi que il
y a pas mal d'injonction au niveau de
bah de la lutte enfin comment dire c'est
pas la lutte mais le le les efforts
qu'on peut faire pour limiter le
changement climatique euh il y a
énormément de d'injonction qui est faite
à l'échelle individuel du comportement
qu'on peut tous avoir les uns les autres
euh je pense qu'il faut pas oublier
aussi qu'on fait tous du mieux qu'on
peut et c'est pas parce que on mange une
fois un steak que que forcément nos
petits enfants vont nous tuez quoi nos
futurs petits enfants donc je pense que
quand tu parlais de santé mentale et
tout euh on fait tous du mieux qu'on
peut je pense que je vais essayer de pas
juger les autres c'est quand même bien
chacun fait vraiment du mieux qu'il peut
du mieux qu'il peut et il faut pas
s'interdire aussi de temps en temps de
bah de profiter de la vie après si
profiter de la vie ça veut dire faire un
aller-retour euh euh à à Tokyo euh juste
pour un weekend réfléchis encore
peut-être mais mais après je vais pas
t'empêcher de le faire ok je j'espère ne
pas avoir trop dit de grosses bêtises là
parce que j'étais vraiment en rou libre
non non c'est ça c'est intéressant euh
j'avais une question sur non j'ai perdu
ma question ouais et
sur B du coup ce qui ce qui moi me tu
l'épine on va dire c'est que du coup
d'une certaine manière dans ta vidéo par
exemple sur euh le plantage d'arbres
dans dans les solutions on va dire que
tu propose c'est souvent des solutions
qui se j'ai l'impression he qui se
réfèent au fait de ne rien faire
finalement et on en revient encore un
peu à cette notion de complexité vu la
complexité de la nature est-ce que
justement la solution c'est pas juste de
respirer un bon coup et de ne pas agir
euh est-ce que tu aurais des est-ce que
tu est-ce que je vise juste oui oui bah
en général je saurais pas dire comme
comme vous disiez aussi ce qui est vrai
dans un cas ne l'est pas forcément dans
un autre mais c'est vrai que un des
trucs qui était recommandé les
recommandations que je donne à la fin
elles sortent pas de mon chapeau hein
c'est des chercheurs qui qui les ont
doné euh c'était effectivement plutôt
que de planter des arbres d'attendre le
reboisement spontané parce que tu as les
bonnes espèces qui se mettent au bon
endroit dans les bons assemblages comme
il faut sur le bon sol et à leur rythme
donc effectivement des fois est-ce que
ça vaut pas mieux de juste pas
déforester quoi plutôt que de d'essayer
de planter à côté donc effectivement
peut-être que enfin ça se défend tout à
fait ce que tu dis
ouais plutôt que d'essayer de réparer
nos erreurs d'essayer de juste pas pas
en faire d'autres ou d' faire le moins
possible quoi pas les aggraver ouais h
ça pe ouais j'ai retrouvé un peu ma
question c'est euh sur le fait justement
de ne pas du coup avoir d'avis en tant
que en tant que par
exemple créatrice de contenu avec
parfois des des centaines de de milliers
de de vues euh donc je trouve ça hyper
intéressant un peu le constat que tu
fais qui est souvent qui va souvent
au-delà de ce qu'on ce dont on on sait
déjà donc c'est c'est intéressant mais
on nous on nous a déjà parlé je crois
pendant un de ces lives du fait que si
on après on donne pas un peu des
solutions euh il y a peut-être quelqu'un
d'autre qui va les donner pour toi et
qui aurait peut-être qui va justement
aggraver le le sujet donc est-ce queil y
a pas aussi un petit peu ce risque là en
sans sans donner son avis ou sans sans
pourquoi pas donner de solution même si
la solution ce serait de rien faire le
dire explicitement de telle sorte que au
moins il il y ait pas quelqu'un d'autre
qui arrive et qui dit ah ben voilà
maintenant qu'on c'est ça on va
euh on va planter tous des arbres en
France parce que c'est pertinent des
choses comme ça c'est possible mais je
tiens vraiment pas à avoir une position
prescriptive j'ai vraiment juste envie
de donner des informations aux gens et
que les gens je je considère qu'ils sont
assez intelligents pour prendre
eux-mêmees une décision là où ma
responsabilité s'arrête c'est là mais là
où par contre elle est c'est de bien
transmettre les informations et de faire
en sorte qu'elle soit bien comprise par
la personne après elle prend la décision
qu'elle veut ça m'est égal mais il faut
vraiment que moi j'ai bien fait mon
boulot en amont pour que elle ait
vraiment toutes les cartes en main pour
prendre sa décision après effectivement
elle fait ce qu'elle veut mais c'est là
où je me sépare des enfin où j'essaie de
me distinguer des de ce qu'on appelle
les influenceurs les influenceurs ils
essayent enfin c'est des des leader
d'opinion je ne considère pas du tout
comme c'est enfin les deux sont
synonymes sur Wikipédia je je dis pas ça
env je me considère pas du tout comme un
leader d'opinion je me considère comme
un éclaireur à la limite mais c'est tout
quoi éclaireur c'est pas le bon terme
bon bref je je donne des informations
aux gens et ils font ce qu'ils veulent
après je sais pas comment appeler ça
vulgarisateur non veutou oui c'est bien
oui ouais vulgarisateur c'est
bien ça prend ça ça prend un peu du sens
avec la la vidéo que tu que tu nous as
conseillé sur ta chaîne
sur la Geode comment construire une gode
si le nom je je je ferme une Geode je
crois je ferme une God avec justement
cette cet aspect de vulgarisation qui
qui prend tout son sens j'ai
l'impression est-ce que tu peux nous
dire pourquoi tu tu l'as recommandé donc
c'était plutôt sur le sur le sur la
forme oui c'était sur la forme euh non
bah encore c'est c'est une vidéo qui
recoupe ce qu'on avait dit tout au début
euh je me suis dit j'ai envie de faire
une vidéo qui explique les trois grandes
familles de roche parce que c'est un
truc absolument fondamental en géologie
c'est un truc qu'on apprend au lycée
peut-être même au collège je sais plus
et j'en avais fait un article de blog à
l'époque et l'idée de mélanger les
cailloux et la bouffe ça me faisait
rigoler et enfin de trouver des analogie
entre l'un et l'autre en plus j'aime
bien les deux donc ça tombe bien et euh
et du coup je me suis dit en vidéo ça
peut être mar et je fais comme si
j'étais un restaurant et en fait chaque
plat qu'on me sert c'est une famille de
roche et comme ça j'ai pu expliquer les
différents types de formations il y a
une soupe avec des morceaux enfin avec
des grumeaux dedans et ben ça c'est mon
magma qui devient une roche volcanique
après voilà ce genre de truc et du coup
l'aspect mise en scène et faire
comprendre l'information de manière
visuelle je trouve ça hyper important
même si c'est de la vulgarisation
scientifique mais parce que on est sur
un médium vidéo et du coup faut vraiment
exploiter toutes les possibilités à la
fois sonore visuel et et j'ai pas
d'autre Sonor et visuel c'est bien pour
un truc audiovisuel je pense je vais
m'arrêter là pas mal mais ouais donc je
pense celle-là c'est celle où j'ai
poussé le plus loin la forme mais à
chaque fois j'essaie de de trouver un
truc un peu
différent voilà qu'on puisse me dire
enfin ça ça m'intéresse pas qu'on me
dise ah la vidéo tu parles des trois
familles de roches mais la vidéo où tu
masses de la bouille à BAE ça ça ça me
parle ça j'aime bien et ça marque un peu
plus ses esprits aussi quoi ou on le
voit on le voit dans dans les euh dans
les différents moyens je m'étais un peu
renseigné sur ça sur les différents
moyens de de retenir une information et
l'appel aux différents sens qui
fonctionnent très bien et même là tu
parlais audioovisuel mais quand on voit
la bouille y baisse on je pense on l'a
tous dans dans la bouche aussi on a tous
le gustatif qui qui rentre en jeu voir
l'odeur aussi et euh et c'est vrai que
ça peut ça peut beaucoup plus marquer et
faire et faire passer le message moi je
suis totalement partisan et et je trouve
que qu'à l'école ça de ça pourrait être
encore plus développé surtout je pense
quand quand on est jeune on a encore
plus réceptif à à ce type d'expérience
et moi je suis vraiment un grand un un
un grand passionné de ce type de de
médium de communication et et elle m'a
beaucoup plu merci félicitation oui oui
effectivement pour faire passer
l'information les émotions c'est
toujours bien bon là c'était clairement
le dégoût plus ça va plus c'est pire
mais mais le rire c'est ce que j'essaie
d'utiliser le reste du
temps pareil c'est c'est à dessin donc
car je suis diabolique c'est pas juste
pour vous faire
rire et je me demandais c'est quoi les
quels sont les sujets sur lesquels si
c'est pas indiscret sur lesquels tu tu
travailles
actuellement et qui t'animent
particulièrement alors le prochain je
l'aime d'amour c'est dans la suite d'un
d'un terrain que j'ai fait un voyage que
j'ai fait en Afrique du Sud ou j'ai pris
l'avion non on peut en parler de ça
aussi parce que je le vis pas très
bien on est allé visiter un avec Julien
d'ract science qui m'a invité là-bas on
est allé visiter un cratère de d'impact
de météorite on a fait le tour ça
faisait un petit lac et tout enfin
c'était magnifique et voilà donc vidéo
sur lescatère d'impact de météorite il y
a plein de trucs à dire dessus j'ai fait
une vidéo sur les météorites déjà donc
là je peux parler des cratères d'impact
et aspect géologie vraiment c'est
c'était incroyable à voir déjà donc j'ai
envie de retransmettre ça et puis
l'aspect enfin savoir de tout ce qu' a
apprendre autour de ça quand même pas
tous les jours qu'on voit ça
quoi j'imagine j'imagine voilà ça c'est
la prochaine et puis une autre aussi sur
les les diamants alors pas que les
diamants en fait si l'idée c'est de voir
c'est pas du tout sexy comme je vais le
dire mais ça s'appelle le polymorphisme
des minéraux donc c'est comment le
graphite devient diamant et
réciproquement ouais il y a plein de
minéraux comme ça qui peuvent échanger
il y a la calcite et la ragonite ce
genre de truc et pareil quand j'étais en
Afrique du Sud on a visité à ma demande
par que j'ai très envie une une ancienne
mine de diamant qui était très connu
là-bas je me demande si c'était pas
genre la première en Afrique du Sud un
truc comme ça enfin bref et en la
visitant je me suis rendu compte qu'il y
avait plein plein de trucs à dire sur
l'aspect social historique et politique
et genre vraiment un peu crac c'était
horrible et et du coup je me dis que ça
peut devenir encore mieux que ce que
j'avais imaginer cette vidéo donc j'ai
très très hâte de m'y mettre aussi j'ai
relevé que tu as dit que des diamants
peuvent devenir
oui mais ça se fait au bout de très
longtemps des millions d'années je pense
encore plus que des graphites qui
deviennent diamant ou c'est à peu près
les mêmes ordres de grandeur en terme de
de
temps non le le graphite peut devenir
diamant s'il est ça peut se faire parce
que il y a des diamants artificiels qui
sont faits donc ça peut se faire dans
certaines conditions de température et
de pression mais par contre pour que le
diamant redevienne graphite il me semble
quefin si tu le laisses à l'air libre ça
prend très très très longtemps c'est
pour ça mon titre c'était censé être les
diamants ne sont pas
[Musique]
éternels je trouver peut-être mieux
d'ici là oh pour le le 14 février ça
peut être pas mal ça je note ah note
pour plus tard
et pour rebondir sur la question des
diamants je me demande est-ce que les
diamants c'est présent encore en
abondance
euh sous terre est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on
a des estimations un petit peu des des
des ressources en diamants qu'on peut
continuer à à aller chercher sous terre
euh je me rends pas du tout compte en
fait à quel point c'est une ressource
épuisable alors là je saurais pas te
dire il faut que je note ta question je
me renseignerai mais parce qu'en fait il
se forme très très en profondeur sous
terre ou et après ils sont ramenés en
surface par des éruptions volcaniques
ouais mais les éruptions en question on
en a jamais vu de de mémoire d'omme donc
c'est vraiment des trucs qui sont au
moins plus nous d'accord euh plus vieux
que nos écrits en tout cas euh donc ça
m'a l'air relativement rare mais après
je sais même pas si on a découvert
toutes les enfin tous les réservoirs de
diamants qui peuvent exister sur terre
ouais ouais j'ag on sait dans quel type
de roche ça peut être dans quel type de
formation aussi donc c'est assez limité
mais je saurais pas te dire plus que ça
faut que je recherche ok mais oui
j'imagine que encore une fois enfin même
nos connaissances par rapport à à à ça
sont sont assez limité vu vu la taille
de la planète et malgré nos nos outils
bah en vrai ça pourrait parce que c'est
vraiment un matériau rare et précieux et
du coup c'est un truc intéressant et qui
a été étudié depuis très très longtemps
du coup et puis vraiment ça s dans des
conditions très particulières donc les
roches dans lesquelles on les trouve
c'est pas n'importe quoi et on sait où
elles sont ok donc en vrai il y a
peut-être la réponse faut que je me
renseigne ok
merci avec plaisir est-ce qu'on a des
questions dans le
chat alors j'ai pas d'impression je
pense que tous les tous les sujets qu'on
a abordé ont déjà répondu à beaucoup de
questions première partie aussi sur sur
la
présentation j'ai pas l'impression qu'on
est de deux questions
ok un petit dernier mot sur la la la
vidéo sur la forme que tu nous as que tu
nous as conseillé peut-être une note une
note finale
pour pour pour finir ce live vous
mettrez le lien quelque part c'est
importanten quelque part est-ce qu'on
pourrait peut-être est-ce qu'on pourrait
peut-être essayer de passer très
rapidement l'extrait pour
conclure
allez je pense que on les risques de
démonétisation sont sont faibles Fabl
sa il y a plus de risque de
monétisation ouis
alors je vais la
mettre elle est un peu de contexte c'est
une chanson que j'ai découvert récemment
et c'est une chanson à
texte d'origine guise voilà n'importe
[Musique]
rien
la
[Musique]
musque question dans le chat euh t je
crois de Louis pousin qui dit tes vidéos
changent-elles tes habitudes au
quotidien alors très bonne question
euh la vidéo qui a plus changé mes
habitudes c'est une que j'ai faite en
partenariat avec Lotus la marque de PQ
que je cite comme ça euh c'était oh oui
ah oui merci c'est je voulais la
repartager celle-là j'avais oublié c'est
10 minutes de pur bonheur 10 minutes Z0
euh qu'est-ce que je voulais dire oui
euh donc c'était une vidéo autour des
des écogestes
euh bref euh et et du coup en fait ça
m'a permis de voir l'importance relative
des échogestes les uns par rapport aux
autres et ça oui effectivement ça a
modifié mes mes habitudes euh de me
rendre compte que notamment le bah en
fait l'empreinte numérique elle est pas
si terrible que ça enfin pas si terrible
que ce que j'imaginais par exemple ouais
euh donc voilà on peut faire des lives
ça
va c'est pas si terrible par contre vaut
mieux éviter de manger de la viande
rouge quoi échange ouais à choisir donc
voilà ce ce genre de enfin arriver à
hiérarchiser les priorités comme ça
c'est un truc qui me manquait et c'est
grâce à cette vidéo j'ai fait l'effort
d'aller me renseigner parce que je suis
vraiment trop fléarde sinon j'aurais pas
fait et donc oui ça m'aide mais après il
y a pas que ça ce que je raconte pour
l'histoire de l'empreinte numérique ça
vient aussi de discussion que j'avais eu
avec rodolp notamment pour un live qu'on
avait fait ok euh sur la chaîne de
twitch d'art et et voilà donc c'est pas
juste les vidéos c'est c'est un petit
ensemble de choses euh mais oui ça
change un petit peu mes habitudes ça a
changé mon avis aussi sur les éoliennes
notamment la vidéo en question mais ça
pareil dans la vidéo je je conclu pas en
disant euh bon bah du coup mon avis
c'est que c'est vraiment juste vous de
changé ton avis mais tu en as toujours
pas c'est ça exactement non mais je je
me retiens de le dire parce que je j'ai
peur que ça dcerve le contenu de la
vidéo or la vidéo je fait de la plus
enfin la plus neutre possible quoi
OK c'est parfait mais a priori peut-être
oui yes je rigole pour ce que tu as
posté sur le discord la comparaison
entre le la vidéo de lait et Marie caré
oui mais ouais c'est c'est c'est hyper
intéressant sur un peu les les les
ordres de de grandeur et moi ça c'est un
truc que j'ai remarqué enfin en vrai qui
qui qui est assez évident mais j'en ai
pris véellement conscience assez
récemment c'est sur l'impact écologique
du numérique en fait euh souvent on peut
voir l'impact numérique ou du numérique
en se disant bah il y a la production du
matériel qu'on utilise donc les
smartphones tous les métaux et cetera
c'est effectivement extrêmement polluant
toute la la bande passante des vidéos et
cetera qui est qui est plus ou moins
polluante mais en en faisant un peu mais
en en faisant un peu un tour sur TikTok
parce que je fais de la sensibilisation
au au danger de la surexpéition aux
écrans auprès des collégiens donc il
faut il faut que j'apprenne un petit peu
à métriser ces outils et en faisant en
faisant excuse t'inquiète ouais et en
faisant en faisant un tour sur TikTok je
suis tombé sur les la tendance des h ou
ho c'est h UL et c'est en fait grosso
modo les les utilisateurs de TikTok qui
viennent de faire leur shopping et qui
font le déballage de leur shopping en
direct notamment de marques comme Shine
qui sont hyper enfin qui ont une
empreinte carbone juste immense et en
fait euh ça c'est je trouve la la part
l'impact écologique du numérique qu'on
prend pas toujours forcément en compte
mais c'est le fait que une vidéo TikTok
qui se diffuse à des millions de
personnes et qui incite des millions de
personnes à acheter des vêtements euh
qui viennent de chez Shine là je me dis
qu'on on mesure peut-être assez mal les
les dégâts écologique que ça
provoque ça c'est sûr ouais et euh et
ouais quand je suis en quand je suis en
interaction justement avec en classe
avec les je jeunes je me rends compte à
quel point c'est ancré dans leur dans
leurs habitudes de d'acheter des
vêtements sur internet avec toujours
moins de friction parce que du coup
c'est des plateformes qui
essayent toujours de faciliter justement
l'achat de vêtements en en enlevant le
plus d'obstacles possiblebles donc
maintenant tu peux commander un un truc
juste avec un petit tap en tapotant ton
écran quoi donc bon c'est terrible parce
que j'ai l'impression que c'est une
génération qui est relativement bien
éduquée au au problématique
environnementale au contraire h bah moi
de ce que je vois personnellement c'est
pas si évident que ça ah ouais j'ai donc
moi c'est avec des 4è que je traite donc
ils ont 13 ans 13 14 euh et en fait
j'aborde quasiment toujours la question
de de l'écologie avec eux et de l'impact
du numérique eu et il y en a finalement
assez peu hein qui savent me définir ce
que c'est les gaz à effet de ser
par exemple
ouais
eu je sais pas après je je sais je sais
pas si c'est normal à cet âge là mais je
dois souvent quand même leur refaire un
un gros point sur sur des principes de
base euh donc donc ouais je je je sais
pas trop il y a peut-être il y a
peut-être une conscience justement de
bon ça c'est on est vraiment sur
peut-être même des sciences de comptoir
là que je suis en train de
euh il y a peut-être moi ce que j'ai vu
aussi en travail un petit peu il y a une
conscience que c'est important mais
peut-être pas une une conscience de
de justement des des actions ou des
ordres de grandeur ou ce type de parce
que aussi il y a il y a un flou
informationnel qui doit être vraiment
quand on a beaucoup d'information même
pour pour nous c'est très difficile de
de justement démêler le vrai du faux et
du coup qu'on en entend de parler ça je
pense que tous les jeunes on beaucoup
plus entendu parler que nos nos parents
à leur âge mais à quel point ils ont les
ordres de grandeur à quel point ils ont
les ils ont les les bonnes pratiques ça
peut-être aussi un peu un peu moins un
peu moins évident
ouais je pense aussi c'est là où on
entre en scène justement et c'est là où
science de comptoir ou la fabrique
sociale ou tournesol peut essayer de
d'aider dans ce dans ce flou
informationnel ouais on espère on
esppèire à notre échelle pour ça qu'on
fait
ça est-ce queil y a d'autres questions
dans le twitch je vois pas de question
ni sur Youtube ni sur le twitch moi je
ne vois plus sur
discord
euhouant
ben moi j'ai pas de nouvelles questions
j'ai j'ai beaucoup aimé ces échanges
merci beaucoup d'être d'être venu
échanger avec nous euh merci à vous pour
l'invitation je vais essayer de si si on
aon ton accord de de poster ça sur
Youtube en en replay
ouais bien sûr j'espère que j'ai pas dit
trop de bêtises pas du tout n'ésitez pas
sinon les commentaires sont faits pour
ça les commentaires son corrigez-moi
et ouais bah c'était c'était non c'était
un
plaisir moi j'ai découvert ta ta chaîne
Youtube récemment et je trouve le
contenu est est vraiment top super quali
et arriv à mêler comme ça autant de de
travail de fond de pédagogie et
d'humour franchement chapeau c'est c'est
c'est super donc donc ravi d'avoir pu
échanger avec toi et puis euh bah
j'espère que tu vas continuer sur cette
voie B merci beaucoup je vais essayer je
je note qu'il faut que je traite de plus
d'environnement si je veux être sur
votre
plateforme je prends note non merci
beaucoup pour ces échanges c'était très
très chouette euh merci au public qui
nous a suivi et euh et ouais j'irai fait
un tour sur ta chaîne aussi quand même
fabrique sociale mais avec avec grand
plaisir si jamais tu je si tu regardes
une des vidéos j'attends j'attends ton
retour
alle je te sur tournol
magnif magnifique et ben merci à vous
merci
beaucoup bonne
[Musique]
soirée